Thank you for coming your life. It's a fight time.
Okay.
So I want to pick up in volume 15, June the 21st, 1923.
And I have a VIP on this one.
I was doing my usual adoration to my crucified good.
And I was saying to him, I enter into your will,
or rather give me your hand and place me in the immensity of your will yourself.
Now, we're inclined to just say, I fuse in your holy will.
But look at the way Louisa says, look, give me your hand, and you put me there yourself.
Okay, that is to make absolutely certain that this fusing actually happens.
Okay, that I may do nothing which is not the effect of your most holy will.
Now, while I was saying this, I thought to myself, how is this?
The divine will is everywhere. I'm already in it.
And yet I say, I enter into your will. This is important now because it answers the question
as to why you have to keep doing it. Is that okay?
Because I've had lots of questions with people saying to me,
but if I do the convenient act in the morning, surely that's enough for the day.
Well, Jesus says it isn't. Watch this.
Now, he's talking to Louisa who's at the highest level of union with God
that I've ever come across in any saint. Okay.
So Louisa said, how is this? The divine will is everywhere.
I'm already in it. And yet I say, I enter into your will.
But while I was thinking of this, my sweet Jesus moving in my interior told me,
my daughter, yet there is a great difference between one who prays and acts because my will
envelops her. Would you ever color that? Being everywhere by its own nature.
And one who of her own will, having the knowledge of what she does within herself
enters into the divine sphere of my will to operate and pray.
So over and above the fact that the divine will is in everything and is everywhere,
is that we actually specifically ask at a particular moment that the divine will
would actually take over and help us to pray at that level.
Because we know from our experience that you may actually
fuse at one particular moment and then a couple of hours later,
discover you haven't even remembered. So we do actually slip in and out.
Okay. So he's saying it's actually important.
So do you know what happens? He says, it happens is when the sun fills the earth with its light,
though the light and the heat are not the same at all points, as we know.
Some countries, it's hotter and other countries, it's cooler.
At some points, there is shade and at other points, there is direct light and the heat is more intense.
Now, who enjoys more light? Who feels more heat? One who is in the shade?
Or one who at those points where the light is not covered with the shade?
However, one cannot say that where there is shade, there is no light.
It's very interesting. The light is there, but the intensity of the light depends on your decision
to go out into the sun or to come in and sit down or to go into the shade.
That's your decision. And he's saying it's our decision to actually let the divine will take over
at a particular moment. Although where there is no shade, the light is more vivid, of course,
and the heat is more intense. Even more, the rays of the sun seems to invest and absorb the creature.
And if the sun had reason and was able to think and one creature exposed herself of our own will
to its burning rays and in the name of all said to it, thank you, sun, for your light and for all
the goods that you produce by filling the earth. For all, I want to give you the return of the good
that you do what glory, honor, and satisfaction with the sun not receive. So the importance of us
actually in the name of all, fusing in the divine will and deliberately spreading that light and
grace and beauty and glory everywhere. Now, it's true that my will is everywhere. That's Sam 139.
Where can I go from your spirit? Where can I flee from your face? If I go to the heavens, you are
there. If I go into the depths of shell, you are there and darkness is not dark to you. The night
is as bright as the day. So since my will is everywhere, but the shade of the human will does
not allow the soul to feel the vividness of the light. Now, I love that the shade of the human will.
This is the we are so used to operating on the much lower level of our own will. And he says the
shade of that doesn't allow you to experience the intensity of God's presence and all the good
that it contains. On the other hand, I love this on the one hand and on the other hand, it's very
Jewish. On the other hand, by wanting to, wanting to enter into my will, the soul lays down her own
will. So in deliberately fusing, we are deliberately putting aside our own will. And she removes the
shade of her own volition. And my will makes its vivid light shine. Now, it's when he gives you
the comparison with the sun and the shade that what he's actually saying is much more clear.
So at that point, the divine will invest her. It transforms her into light itself. Now,
we're only at volume 15. And as we go on into the higher volumes, the process is that we have to be
spiritualized or the other language is divinized. And the church has taught us that from the beginning
that the second person of the blessed trinity became man or humanized in order to divinize us.
Okay, so that's the process that he's doing. But in these writings, that spiritualization or
divinization is also called being transformed into light, because God is light. It also speaks
about us being transformed into love because God is love. So God is love, God is light. So we have
to be transformed into him. So when the moment of death comes, this tiny little spark goes into the
fire. This tiny little light goes into the great light. This tiny little spark of love goes into
the furnace of love. And someone who's operating this way in the divine will, that movement is
direct. It doesn't have to be down below to try and get some preparation done. Is that okay?
And the soul plunged into my eternal volition says to me,
"Thank you, O Holy Supreme Volition, for your light and for all the goods that you produce by
filling heaven and earth with your eternal will. For all, I want to give you the return of the good
that you do." This is us saying, "I love you. I adore you. I praise you. I bless you. I thank
you for everybody." And I feel such honor, glory, and satisfaction that no other equals it. Now,
why does no other equal it? It's simply that you're doing it on the level of the divine will.
And the reason why the saints of the latter days will be greater than the saints of the former days
is just very simply that we will be operating in the divine will. And the others were operating
from the human will. It's actually very simple. It doesn't mean that we were more heroic in certain
actions or anything. So we're operating on a different level. That's like saying. The first
airplanes that they flew in the skies, the pilots were very, very brave because they were flying
bits of things that they hardly knew how it worked. And then they improved the airplanes and it was
so much better to fly. But now when you fly in a 747, the comparison between that and the guys
who managed to get themselves off the ground, there's just no comparison. But it's still flying.
How do you get it? So all the saints that have come up all during the history of the church
at various stages, they all had their own heroism. But there's no comparison with operating in the
divine levels. Is that okay? So my daughter, how many evils the shade of one's will does, or
this needs to be colored, it cools the soul down. That really needs to be colored. The more we operate
out of our own will, it just cools the souls down. It produces sloth. That means you're not moving
spiritually. You know the sloth doesn't like moving? It produces sleep. That means you are not
living an act of life and sluggishness. Now they're all aspects of the same thing. Sloth,
sleep and sluggishness. That means you're going nowhere fast. The opposite for one who lives in
the divine will. Okay. So after this, Louisa said, I found myself outside of myself. And I saw
as if contagious diseases were to come. So this is your Amos 37 again and Isaiah 6410. The Lord
never does anything without showing the prophets first. I saw as if contagious diseases were to come
and many people were carried to leper hospitals. Now this is 1923. The only language Louisa has
is a leper hospital. We call it an isolation unit. Now who were the people who were put into
isolation units? There were TB patients. Okay. TB was very strong at this early part of the 20th
century. So that's why she calls them leper hospitals. It means isolation hospitals. A general
fright was raining and many other maladies of new kinds were turning up. Okay. But I hope that
Jesus may want to placate himself by his merits, by the merits of his most holy precious blood,
she said. So she's seeing that one of the great chastisements is contagious diseases. We still have
them. Ebola is a terrible one today. Because while they can control it somehow, they can't really.
Okay. So I want to go on to June the 28th, 1923. So how in creating man God cast into him the seed
of his eternal love. I think this is fantastic. I was thinking of the immense love of my sweet
Jesus, Louisa. Please turn off your mobile phones. I was thinking of the immense love of my most
sweet Jesus. And he let me see all souls as though bound inside a net of love. And he said to me,
my daughter in creating man, I cast into him many seeds of love. If God didn't give us this love,
we wouldn't have it. We wouldn't have any ability to love anybody. He said seeds of love are in his
intelligence, in his eyes, in his word, in his heart, in his hands, in his feet, in everything I
placed a seed of love. Now look at all the expressions of love that need to come out of us. Through
the use of our minds, our intelligence, through our eyes, you can look at someone with love, can't
you? You can look at someone with contempt as well. Through your heart, your word, your hands,
your and so on. And I was to work it from the outside. And together with me, I placed all
created things in order to make this seed sprout and to grow according to my will. So the book of
Genesis tells us in chapter two, that man was put into a garden of Eden, a garden of paradise.
In other words, the creation that God made for us, and he tells us, he was specifically made for
us, was to enable us to be able to grow. You put a person into circumstances to enable them to grow.
We put children into schools hoping they will grow. They're supposed to grow intellectually in
every other way. Notice I said supposed to know that the dreadful things happening. So he put man
into the earth with all the correct circumstances for him to grow to his fullness. So having been
placed by an eternal God, this seed was also eternal. Now where he's going to with this is,
the only baggage allowed on our return flight to heaven is love. No other baggage is allowed.
All other baggage is prohibited. And the only thing that will get you into heaven is love.
So if somebody dies with practically no love in their hearts, they have to gain something in
purgatory. Otherwise there's no entry into heaven. Because nothing outside of God can go into heaven.
Nothing. And God is love and God is light. So if there's darkness in us that darkness has to be
dealt with, if there's any absence of love that has to be dealt with as well. So man contains
an eternal love within himself. Okay. So beside that you can put John 1334-35
where Jesus said, "You are to love one another in the same way as I loved you." Okay. And you can
also put John 59, "As the Father has loved me, so I have loved you, so you are to love one another,
so you are to love one another, therefore at a divine level. Because this is an eternal love.
So man contains an eternal love within himself and an eternal love goes towards him constantly.
Now an eternal love has been put into us and an eternal love is coming towards us all the time
drawing us into itself. To receive the return of the seeds of the eternal love cast into man
and to give him new and eternal love. In fact, I wanted to be inside of man as a seed and outside
of him as a worker. So he wants to be firmer on the outside and seed on the inside. It's all God's
work. Okay. That's Ephesians 210. We are God's work of art created in Christ Jesus.
So notice he wants to be the doer all the time. And you'll see that in all the early volumes that
Jesus was saying to Louise, "Let me do this. I know what I'm doing. I know what needs to be done.
What you need to do is surrender to my action." Okay.
So I wanted to be inside of man as a seed and outside of him as a worker in order to form
in him the tree of my eternal love. Now at the top of the page what I've written for myself
is the tree of life is the tree of eternal love. The tree of life is the tree of eternal love.
And the tree of life is also the cross, Calvary. Okay.
And we see on Calvary what eternal love actually looks like that the person who loves will pay
any price to save people who don't deserve it. Okay. So the tree of life, and we're going to
get more of these messages as well because Jesus himself is the tree of life. And so he makes us
like him. So the love that's put into us is a tree of eternal love. Okay. So he wants to produce
in us a tree of eternal love. Now God is love one John four seven to seventeen.
And what would be the good of man to have eyes filled with light if he did not have external
light to illuminate them. Now that's Sam 36 nine Lord in your light we see light.
If there was no light at all in this room the fact that you have eyes wouldn't help would it?
No, because you actually need light in order to be able to see. And all the saints all down the
centuries have told us that when we are in prayer and we're trying to receive from the Lord they
call it enlightenment. That means I receive more light. I understand more I can go more towards God
and calling it enlightenment is correct. I receive more light. Okay. So he would remain in the dark
if he didn't have external light. So in order to enjoy the effect of the light it takes an
internal light of the eye as well as an external light of the sun to illuminate. Is that fascinating?
Okay. So he's talking about he has put a seed of eternal love into us. He is the eternal love
coming towards us. And if we don't have his love the little seed in us has nothing to actually
go towards our love. It's the same for the mind. If man had no speech to express his thought
the life of his intelligence would die. It's not interesting and would be without fruit and so
with all the rest. So Jesus continues I loved man so much that I not only cast into him the seed
of my eternal love but I put him under the waves of my eternal love. Now think of somebody in the sea
and if you're under the waves of the sea you're under this immense thing coming towards you because
his love is eternal absolute, infinite and immeasurable and all the rest of it. I put him under the
waves of my eternal love and when you're doing the hours of the passion particularly the closer you
get to the actual crucifixion itself here Louisa saying the the ocean of love that's expressing
itself through him and that the the greater the challenge the higher his love goes to reach the
challenge and it's it's a fascinating um someday I'll put it on paper for you. It's a fascinating
challenge it's like it's like somebody running in a hurdle race and because the person is doing well
they raise the hurdle and the person raised is their game and then the hurdle is raised and
the person raises their game and so on and so on until what actually happened in Jesus' dying was
the ultimate of human experience the ultimate of human endurance the ultimate in human patience
the ultimate in human love and you can go on and off was actually reached
and this is why in the end both John's gospel specifically or particularly says that in the last
hour there was silence they could not believe what they were looking at that no matter what you did
to him there was going to be no darkness no negativity no reaction no nothing his love was higher than
anything you could throw at him so in a in a much smaller game that's what life does to us as well
that when you pass the first test then he tries you to see will you take a bigger one
then he tries to see will you take a bigger one because some people you know don't want PhDs
you know when I passed you know and I've heard Catholics say oh if I get into heaven by the skin
of my teeth and then they stop saying that to me because I told them to stop insulting God
I said getting into heaven by the skin of your teeth is no glory to God and it's certainly no
glory to you either because it means you're too damn lazy to try you won't make any effort
you won't let them bring you further you won't let them challenge you you know so they stop when
you react like that you're not reacting nicely you see you're not being all religious with them
sometimes they need just a real dose of reality and the Lord has put this love inside of us
he has put these waves of love around us and he tells us I have to tell you now it's in volume 7
I have to tell you this he says every single thing that happens to you good,
bad or indifferent you are to take as a speciality of his love look at my garden it's a speciality
of his love so it means that there's a hurdle you have to jump now do you get it
and if you if you only look at it in a human way and a worldly way you're not going you
know I even go to see the hurdle you're not going to know that there is something to jump
and the thing is if you can't jump but ask him to lift you you can always cheat you know
you can say Lord I'm not able to jump that but you could lift me and then we'll we'll pretend
that I did it by myself so there is this challenge and you can see with Louisa all the time that
she's being challenged more and more and more as well and it's to see how far you will go
in reaching out for life and in reaching out for love and in reaching out for the ultimate
in the high call reaching for the skies okay so so I love man so much that I not only cast into
him the seed of my eternal love but I put him under the waves of my eternal love which is spread
throughout the whole of creation so it doesn't matter where you go on earth it doesn't matter
what people you meet it doesn't matter what circumstances you meet this same mystery is happening
okay so it spreads throughout the whole of creation in order to make it germinate in him
and to overwhelm him completely with my eternal love now Jesus actually says that I think when he's
being crowned with thorns I want to overwhelm them with my love so if the light of the sun shines in
his eyes that's number one it brings him a wave of my love number two if he takes water to quench
his thirst number three food to nourish himself they bring him the wave of my eternal love number
four if the earth lays itself under his feet and remains firm to allow his step it brings him the
wave of my love number five and six the flower gives off its fragrance if the fire unleashes the
seed everything brings my eternal love so that's why I wanted to remind you of volume seven because
it's actually very like what it says there except that he uses the words that everything that happens
to you is a specialty of my love it's the specialty bit I underlined for myself but this isn't enough
he said I myself am with them that's called Emmanuel God with us Emmanuel Matthew 28 20 I will be with
you on all the days that are coming even to the very end I'm working inside and outside that if
that's Ephesians 210 and Philippians 1 6 the Lord will finish the job if you actually allow him
I'm working inside and outside what am I doing I want to arrange to confirm and to seal all my
similes in the soul of man so that as I give him eternal love eternal love he may also give to me
because if love doesn't have its return unrequited love is the greatest pain so the creature also
can love me with eternal love only on the divine level of course because he contains this seed
but to my highest sorrow man suffocates this seed that is with his selfishness man of course
meaning all of us and then it happens that even though my love keeps him under its waves
he does not feel the light which my love sends him because having suffocated the seed he becomes
blind and even though he burns he does not get warm and as much as he may drink and eat his thirst
is not quenched and he's not nourished where there is no seed there's no fecundity it's not
interesting so I love it when he shows you the opposite as well because then you clear it I mean
as a teacher I always found it very important to tell the students what a thing was not and then
tell them what it is but once they had a comparison they were okay you know so July the first 1923
this is prayer in the divine will VIP I was fusing myself in the holy divine will in order to go around
through each person's intelligence and to give to my Jesus the return of love for each thought
of each person but while I was doing this a thought came to me what's the good of praying
this way on the contrary it seems to me that this is nonsense rather than prayer now I could
bet a little bit of money on it that thought didn't come to louisa by herself that this is
most likely the questions that the priests are asking her when they look at these texts and
they're asking her to ask questions louisa doesn't need this information this information is for us
is that okay and my always lovable Jesus moved in my interior that's Luke 17 21 the kingdom of
god is within you and one Corinthians 3 16 no you not that you are the temple of the living god
and that the spirit of god dwells in you so he moved in my interior and he told me my daughter
do you want to know what the good and the effect of this is of what she's just been talking about
that's entering into the divine will going through the intelligence of everybody and
giving god the return of love for them he said my daughter okay when the soul I don't use the
word creature very often because you're talking about souls or human beings or people okay so when
the soul comes to cast a little the little stone of her will into the immense sea of my divinity
that's a lovely way of talking about fusing isn't it as she casts it if her will wants to love
the infinite sea of the waters of my love ripple are agitated and I feel the waves of my love giving
off their celestial fragrance and I feel the pleasure and the joys of my love being agitated
by the little stone of the will of the creature if she adores my sanctity the little stone of the
human will agitates the sea of my sanctity and I feel cheered by the most pure hours of my sanctity
in some whatever the human will wants to do in mine it flings itself like a little stone
into each sea of my attributes I'm as absolutely beautiful
and as it agitates them and ripples them I feel as if I'm given my own things and the honors and the
glory and the love which the creature can give me in a divine manner it's the divine manner that
we're talking about okay you can only do this when you fuse and then he said it's like a person
it's like a very rich person who has the goods in his house he has most fresh founts fragrant
founts warm founts now the images is from the ancient world where only the rich would have a
wonderful fount of water in their own property everybody else was carrying buckets of water on
their heads from the local river or whatever someone else enters into this house and has nothing
to give that person because he possesses everything because in the ancient world if you had a fount
of water in your own property you had everything okay however he wants to please him he wants to
love him and what does he do he takes a little stone and casts it into the fresh fount the water
is being agitated give off a most delicate freshness and the lord of that house enjoys the pleasure
and freshness of his own fount okay he delights in the very goods that he possesses but why because
the other one took the care of agitating that fount since when things are stirred they give off
their fragrance the freshness or the heat that they contain intensely this is what it means to
enter into my will to stir to move my being that i think you need to color to actually move the
divine being okay now what for myself what i do is i put vip beside the move the divine being and
and you say to me do you see how good and lovable and loving and holy and immense and powerful you
are you are everything and i want to move the whole of you in order to love you and to give you a
pleasure and you think that's trivially said that a tiny creature if you if you know how small the
earth is you'll have some idea of the immensity of us just being said because i've said this to you
before that if you take a model of the universe and go looking for the milky way you'll see this
you can actually get this on the internet but don't ask me how you get it i find these things
accidentally you get a model of the universe and it's actually not around it's it's a elliptical
shape and there's a reason for that and if you go looking for the milky way it's one pixel
it's all it is on the on the map of the universe if that's the size of the milky way with all its
trillions of stars then what we're saying here is an is immense okay so if you hold me in on this
one pixel and therefore you multiply it millions of times so you can see the milky way
go looking for the solar system and you find the pixel
that's a speck of a speck in the universe okay and when you manage to home in onto the solar system
you find earth is one of the smallest of the rocks so we're a speck of a speck of a speck
in the universe and we're so big that you nearly have to be at tree level before you see us
and yet we're the most arrogant proud race that ever could exist now for someone a tiny little
creature on this tiny little rock which is only a speck of a speck of a speck in the universe
to be able to move the divine being that is unbelievable okay and to put to let you know how
unbelievable it is and good to give you a sam eight five yet you made us little less than a god
with glory and honor you crowned us giving us power over the works of your hands but immediately
before that the sam says lord what is man that you'd even think of him we're nothing so you can see
that with this reality in in our minds that the nothingness is the only thing that you can present
to the allness quite literally because if we think we're anything in that incredible scene
we're awfully foolish and you see how stupid it is to see politicians and various people
strutting and fretting their hour upon the stage as Shakespeare said and then they're hurting them
or you know what I mean I just look at them I thought that the whole idea how silly they are
and they've no idea that the whole of heaven is looking on you know so it's amazing
so now in the next paragraph we're going to be told something absolutely incredible and
you need to put a VIP even on the paragraph itself and that is each truth that Jesus reveals to us
is a whole new creation that he makes because god's word is creative if he expresses something
it comes into being that's the way it is so having said this Jesus withdrew in my interior
and I was left thinking how good Jesus is it seems to me that he greatly delights in communicating
himself to us poor creatures and that he takes so much pleasure in manifesting his truths that
while he is saying one that very truth is a spur for him and almost pushes him with an irresistible
force to manifest more truths what goodness what love Louisa said and Jesus came out again from my
interior that's your Luke 17 21 again to make sure you keep on reminding yourself that the kingdom
of god is within he came from out from within my interior and placed his face close to mine saying
my daughter you do not know what it means to manifest my truths we would say you don't realize
what I'm saying and this is why you marvel at the the the pleasure and at the irresistible force
that I feel to manifest myself to a human creature and one who is willing to listen to me forms my
joy now all over the Old Testament you have very particularly through the prophets
it's Isaiah it's Jeremiah it's Amos it's the lot of them so I'm not going to give you
one reference I'd have to give them all he says I only ever asked you to listen to me
now those of you who have rare children haven't you said it over and over again
for God's sake would you just listen and what does the human being not to won't listen because if you
don't listen you don't receive the word it's the same thing with us at mass as well the word is
proclaimed that but if we don't listen we don't hear it and listening is not in the ear it's in the
heart and one who's willing to listen to me forms my joy and my delight in conversing with her
because listening means you're going to receive it in your heart you must know that when I manifest
one truth of mine which is not yet known it is a new creation that I make you see in in this divine
will revelation that the Lord is making to Louisa he was creating a whole new era for the human race
it's a new creation that I make and I love very much to release from myself the many goods and
secrets that I contain but as much as I may speak since I am that act ever new which never repeats
itself look at that now again there's a a summary of the Old Testament no matter how often the
people of God broke the covenant he never patched it up never he would give them something new
something new he'd give them a new dispensation he'd give them new rules he'd give them new whatever
he doesn't patch and remember Jesus said that he wouldn't make Christianity a patch on Judaism do
you remember and he doesn't put new wine into old wineskins he he's ever new okay remember St. Augustine
in the fourth century or beauty so ancient and so new later I loved thee okay so he said I always
desire to say more and as I speak I have always more things which I would like to say this illustrated
very well in Genesis chapter one when he said let there be light then he got all excited about
it and decided he wanted to diss that and the other and all then he kept on speaking things into
being in fact in fact the Hebrew verb that is used for to create in the first line of the book of
Genesis is "bara b-a" or "a" if it's in phonetics okay "bara" and it means to speak something into
existence from nothing in a divine manner that's a long statement for one little four letter word
"bara" it's to speak something into existence in a divine manner the other way you'd say it is to
declare something into existence for example the third sentence of of Genesis chapter one is
"viamer Elohim vehi" or "et behi" or you heard me repeat something didn't you so "viamer" and God
said let there be light "behi" "et behi" or and there was light so it's spoken into existence
that's actually what they're telling you and so Genesis chapter one is actually a great help to
understanding this he speaks things into existence if the Lord speaks to you in prayer and says
forgive he gives you the power to forgive it's not a command as in do this or else it's not that
he actually enables you to do it it's terribly important for us to understand things like that
so I always desire to say more he said and as I speak I've always more new things which I would
like to say because that newness is never exhausted in me I am always new in love new in beauty new
in contentment new in harmonies new in everything and ever new if you remember in the hours of the
passion the moment when Judas kissed Jesus on the face you remember at Louisa said that Jesus gave
him new love she gave Judas a love he had never given before to try and see if you could conquer
this soul it's very interesting new love but if we if we know that it's always new then it means
you can always go back to him and start all over again it's terribly important for us to start all
over again terribly important say Lord okay I missed again can we start again and he says no
problem I'm new life I'm new love everything with him is new and it's the most wonderful thing if
you just get this what he's saying this is why he said I do not tire anyone because we don't get
tired of something is new I've always new things to say and new things to give and the irresistible
force that pushes me to manifest myself is my love so love is always wanting to give
it is an outpouring of love that I had when I issued creation this is terribly important because
again you go back to Genesis chapter one and you're hearing let this come into being and that and
everything is absolutely beautiful and everything's in harmony and everything balances everything
else and everything has its own place and everything and he's delighting in bringing everything into
being it's really fantastic but he takes the same delight in bringing all the spiritual realities
into being in us he takes well I shouldn't say the same delight it's probably infinitely greater
because it's greater America getting any cooperation from us he said it's always an outpouring of love
when I issued creation everything can be seen in the whole universe was all inside of me
love made the shadow of my light overflow from my interior no it's the shadow because the whole
of creation can only be the tiniest tiniest shadow of the reality but he tells us that if we would
only contemplate creation we would find him and I created the sun the shadow of my immensity
and of my harmonies and I extended the heavens harmonizing them with many stars and celestial
spheres these and other things which I created were nothing other than shadows of mine which I
released from myself and my love had its outpouring and I took great delight in seeing what was contained
inside of me spread out in little particles hovering all over creation it's not very interesting
so he's saying that everything in creation is a manifestation of his love so you will
understand therefore why he's saying to us that he wants us to put our I love you on everything
as well so that he gets a return of love so in the next paragraph he's going to contrast
the difference between substance and reality substance and not just shadow now what will be my
joy in manifesting my truths which are not shadows of mine which come out of me but the substance of
the goods I contain within me these are the spiritual realities that he's actually revealing
in this divine will material he's revealing the essence of himself the divine will is the essence
as he calls it the operating part of the Trinity so he's revealing things about himself that have
never been known before you have to go through most of the Old Testament before you will hit on
anything that really says there's three persons in God they kind of got a hint of it they got a
shadow of it but they didn't really get the full thing and so the full thing comes with Jesus in
the New Testament and now what he's doing is revealing as much as we can take who he really is
that tells you of course we've moved on towards the end times here here now it's the substance of
the goods that contain in me which speak of me not in a mute language like all created things
that's Sam 19 verses 1 to 6 that all creation speaks in a mute language about the glory of God
but now here I speak with clear sonorous and eloquent voice and which since my word is creative
like a new creation I create in the soul the truths that I manifest now you often hear
Louisa saying after she has received a new revelation from the Lord that she's completely
stunned by this and she's completely taken up in it and for days he won't speak again and the
reason is that she has to absorb it she has to adjust to this completely new revelation and she's
to try and express it for us as well it can take her days to do that and if with one fiat I created
many things in manifesting my truths it's not just one fiat that I pronounce but as many words for
as many are needed in order to manifest and to have souls understand that which I want them to
understand in other words there's no point in him revealing things about himself as the divine will
if we have no understanding I don't know if you've ever gone to a lecture in which the
lecture was going on and on and on and you hadn't it though now that I had that experience in the
university with a biochemistry class and I thought he could be double touched to me doesn't matter
what he writes on the board doesn't mean anything I just didn't get it and that was it so knowledge
without understanding is useless and so what he says is that we must actually understand so I want
to give you Jose a four six without knowledge and understanding the people perish that's Jose a four
six and Luke 1152 understanding is important and there's a very lovely moment and it's
in the gospel of Saint Mark my mind is telling me chapter seven but don't trust my mind
I'll give you the contest and you'll recognize it Jesus had worked the miracle of the loaves
and he was taking the apostles on a boat trip to the other side of the lake and they had no food
and they were all worried about the fact that they had no food and he's only worked a miracle
for five thousand people and he he'd heard him and he said but didn't you get it didn't you understand
how many people were there five thousand was there enough food from yet I was who provided it that
did it occur to them to say give us a bit of bread in the boat he said do you not understand
you see the knowledge without understanding is useless absolutely useless and because they had
understood so little they didn't manage very well when it came to the passion it was only when the
Holy Spirit came to them afterwards in giving them wisdom understanding council fortitude knowledge
that was when things began to come together for them so he has to speak to us in a way that
and give us the grace at the same time to grasp it now I'm sure you've had the experience of
reading something in Louisa and you didn't get it yeah have you been there okay that's all right
just keep going because at that moment your soul wasn't open to the understanding but if you go
back and read it at another point maybe at a more prayerful moment you'll get it there's nothing
wrong with your intellect it's that to for the soul to grasp something sometimes you to go deeper
in prayer so that the Holy Spirit with the knowledge and understanding the two can come together and
you say oh yeah that's what it means so I want them to understand you need to put a VIP beside that
this is one of the reasons why we have classes and we try to explain the thing that doesn't mean I
understand everything god help us imagine then he said what my contentment is in manifesting my
truths to the soul who not in mute language but with the speaking voice will manifest my goods
and my truths to others now those of you who are teaching for the VIP beside that will you
he said try and imagine my contentment when someone with the speaking voice will manifest my
goods and my truths to others this is why we're encouraging people to share with others so I want
to give you Sam 119 verse 130 I want to give you Proverbs 2 4 and Proverbs 4 5 and then you can
put etc because there's so many references to it okay so why does she manifest my goods and my
truths to others it's in order to infuse into them the good that she has received now those of you
who are already running classes know that you can only pass on to somebody else what you've grasped
it's as simple as that so when I started teaching divine will first I was a newcomer myself
and so as a complete newcomer I had a class can you imagine and so when we get to something we were
all at the same stage and I say anybody got any ideas none of us at any we'll revisit that some
other time we'd move on and you got it you got it eventually you go back and say ah that's what
he was saying but the best thing to do is just simply to move on you know but you also find if
you're if you're teaching a class that in trying to explain it to somebody else you'll get an insight
isn't that right yeah that's usually what the Lord does and so the teacher can get something
they've not got from anybody else because at that moment the Lord wants everybody in your class
to get the thing so he'll give it to you it's not because you're any better it's that you're
willing to share it this is this is one of the reasons why I'm encouraging everybody to
get a small little group and start sharing from the beginning okay we'll be telling you much
more about that in September therefore in manifesting my truths my love finds its outpouring and becomes
festive and I greatly love one who is willing to listen to me put a VIP beside that I greatly
love someone who is willing to listen to me so that that is when we are willing to take this on board
and give him a chance to create a tragedy inside of us okay so july the fifth 1923
luisa is looking at that moment when jesus was presented to pilot so this is john 19
I was accompanying my suffering jesus in the hours of his most bitter passion especially when
jesus was presented to pilot by the jews and was accused and pilot not satisfied with the
simple accusations that were making against him returned to question him in order to find a
reason sufficient to condemn him or to release him and jesus beginning to speak in my interior
there's your luke 17 21 again and told me my daughter everything in my life is profound
mystery now what i underline is profound in other words we all know the gospels we've all heard a
certain level of explanation of the gospels and when everybody's finished explaining the gospels
with all the insights they ever have we haven't touched the surface because it's all profound
mystery it's all sublime teachings is what jesus is saying now most of the time we don't hear sublime
teachings we hear very trivial teachings because people are not praying enough and they're not
searching enough to actually go into any kind of depth everything in my life is profound mystery
and sublime teachings in which man must reflect himself in order to imitate me jesus is the only
model you must know that the pride of the jews was so great now the jews is the jewish leaders
okay the words are used in exactly the same way here as is used in the gospels it always means
the leaders was so great now that's matthew five twenty and matthew six verses one to four
especially in the false sanctity that they profess that's your matthew six one to four in
other words they had the right clothes they had the right job they were in the right place they
were saying the right things but they were not living that way now we have the problem that same
problem in the church today not with everyone thank god because of which they were held as
upright and conscientious men so that's why you get matthew six one two four don't pray like them
don't fast like them and don't do anything like them because they're looking for all kinds of
stuff on the outside and so they looked as if they were upright and conscientious men
that they believed that by just presenting me themselves this is very very interesting
they believed their own lies you see that by saying that they had found me at fault and guilty
to death that Pilate would have to believe them and condemn me without making them undergo any
interrogation it's very very interesting these men because they were in their jobs so long dressed
in their wonderful robes for so long and carrying out all these rights for so long believed their
own lie that because i'm dressed as a minister of god that i am that person but of course in the
church we learned rather early that the the habit doesn't make the monk that's one of the very early
sayings of the saints the habit doesn't make the monk and these men presumed that if they arrived
in their wonderful robes in the presence of Pilate who was a pagan and a leader in the politics
out there that Pilate should take their word for it it's amazing and one of the shocks in the
the whole passion of Jesus which i actually love is that Pilate let them know that not only did he
not believe anything out of their mouth they absolutely despise them and he could read them
and he could read their their wrong motivation and everything that doesn't make him any good either
but they could see it so Jesus stood in the middle and there was a battle going on between Pilate
and the priests and Jesus was the pawn it's amazing when you see it that way and
so more so since they were dealing with a gentile judge whom they despised you see
who had no knowledge of god nor a conscience i think that's rather interesting coming from Jesus
saying that Pilate had no conscience do you find that interesting yeah but god disposed
things differently in order to confound them and to teach superiors now superiors means anybody
over anybody else whether it's a pope a cardinal a bishop a priest a religious superior a teacher
anybody to teach superiors that as good and holy as the people who charge sorry to teach
superiors that as good and holy as the people who charge a poor accused one may appear
they should not believe them easily but they should almost overwhelm them with many interrogations
to see if there is any truth and that under the appearance of goodness that there's not some
jealousy or rank or the intention to snatch some aspired position or dignity from their superiors
by making their way into their hearts and they're rather interesting Jesus absolutely insists that
if somebody accuses somebody else that that person should go under incredible scrutiny what happens
in the court the opposite it's the victim that's that's scrutinized all the time and many people many
women for example who have gone to court saying that someone has raped them they feel raped the
second time in court because they are treated as guilty until proven innocent and the law
should be the other way around yeah scrutiny makes one know people Jesus said and it confounds them
and it shows that one does not trust them and you see it would prevent also people in power from
misusing people who are not in power and in seeing themselves not appreciated they dismiss
the thought of aspiring to positions or of accusing others yet it would be a good cure if you got a
good dressing down in court you know what I mean how much harm superiors do when keeping their eyes
closed trusting in false goodness and not in proven virtue look at that they assign a position or
they pay heed to someone who is accusing someone else of some fault how humiliated the Jews that the
Jewish leaders were left in not being easily believed by Pilate of course that only made them
even more angry with Pilate and they forced Pilate to kill Jesus in the end in going through many
interrogations and if he surrendered to condemning me it was not because he believed them that is
perfectly clear in John 18 from verse 28 to John 19 16 that's where this dialogue is coming out of
it's perfectly clear Pilate didn't believe them and it was pure revenge and anger that made them
force Pilate that's John 18 28 John 18 28 and it goes on to 19 16
and so he did not believe them but because he was forced to so as not to lose his position
now look at this very clear explanation of the the passion because it's extremely clear
in John 18 to 19 there that in the end Pilate knew something very clear that somebody was going to
lose it was either Jesus or himself so he decided it's not going to be me
so that's why Jesus says here he was a man without conscience you know and the strange thing is
Pilate did lose everybody in that in the trial of Jesus lost everybody Jesus lost his life that day
Pilate lost his job when Caesar heard that he had condemned an innocent man
all the the priests lost not only their jobs but their lives when the Romans came in in AD 70
and they killed many priests on the altar before they desecrate as part of their desecration of
the temple and then the temple was destroyed and then the city was destroyed so they all lost
so it was a situation that you know looking at it from a purely human point of view you'd say
this was the craziest thing they ever did and this confounded them that's the the Jewish leaders
so much that in their extreme confusion and profound humiliation they remained impressed on
their foreheads like a mark and they never got over it more so since they noticed more rectitude
and more conscience in a Gentile judge than in themselves at least Pilate wanted to examine the
thing at least Pilate said now listen here this man is not a criminal and three times he proclaimed
Jesus innocent how necessary and just scrutiny is Jesus says it casts light and calm into the
truly good people and confusion into those who are evil find that very interesting
so and when wanting to scrutinize me also Pilate asked are you a king where is your kingdom
I wanted to give another sublime lesson by saying I am king and I wanted to say
but you know what my kingdom is my kingdom is my pains my blood my virtues now he lost Pilate
anyway but he would have lost him a million times with that kind of an answer okay
this is the true kingdom that I possess not outside of myself but within me Luke 17 21
now but Jesus is saying there is you have a kingdom that kingdom is within you
okay and you are the lord of that kingdom if you actually are in control of the passions
and the desires and the ambitions and the this and the that and the other okay it becomes the
kingdom of God when you hand that over to Jesus the true king okay and the kingdom of God is
able to be established in us don't know if I'm making sense am I and in charismatic prayer groups
they sing rain in me sovereign lord rain in me well it's in the divine will you actually learn
how to do that in its fullness okay and that's when the true conquering has taken place
and so Jesus said my kingdom is my pains my blood and my verses what he's what he's saying there is
that he conquers his kingdom in all of us through his pains his blood and his virtues
this is the true kingdom that I possess not outside of me but within what one possesses on the outside
is not a true kingdom nor a safe kingdom naturally enough because as soon as you become the top person
in politics everybody else is looking for the job isn't that it and one kingdom knocks out another
kingdom in order for them to take over and so on so it's not safe because that which is which
is not inside a man can be taken away it can be usurped and it can be you can be forced to leave it
but that which is inside nobody will be able to take away from him its dominion will be eternal
within him is that wonderful the characteristics of my kingdom are my wounds my thorns and my cross
therefore I have to say to you that for the characteristics of his kingdom to be manifested
in us it's in thorns and wounds and cross okay I know we prefer carpets and flowers and stuff you
know I do not act like other kings who make their people live outside of themselves unsafe and
eventually even starving not me I call my people to dwell inside the rooms of my wounds john 14
verses 1 to 2 my father's house there are many rooms and there's one for you fortified and sheltered
by my pains they're thirst quenched by my blood they're hunger satisfied by my flesh
this alone is true reigning that's Romans 5 17 to reign in life with Christ
it's 1 Corinthians 4 8 and 2 Timothy 2 12 this alone is true reigning all other reigns are
reigns of slavery of dangers and of death while in my reign there is true life this true life is
a life that goes into everlasting life okay how many sublime teachings how many profound mysteries
are in my words and that's why we have to study them more and more each soul should say to herself
in pains and in sufferings in humiliations and in abandonment by all and in practicing true virtues
this is my kingdom now that should be underlined in green white and gold I'm going to read it again
each soul should say to herself when she's experiencing pains and sufferings and humiliations
and abandonment by all and at the same time practicing true virtue this is my kingdom
and it's not subject to perishing no one can take this away from me no one can even touch it
on the contrary my kingdom is eternal and divine similar to that of my sweet Jesus my sufferings
and pains certify it for me and render my kingdom more fortified and fierce in such a way that
in the face of my great strength no one will be able to war against me now who's the one who
wants to wage war against you the demon okay so this is the kingdom of peace to which all my children
aspire okay so let's give you something about peace sam nine six Jesus is the king of peace
Sam so I should I say Sam Isaiah nine six you see I'm looking at another reference there Isaiah nine
six Isaiah twenty six three
Isaiah twenty six three says you keep him in perfect peace whose mind is stayed on you I want to give
you Sam for eight twenty nine eleven and thirty four fourteen I want to give you Luke two fourteen
John 14 27 and Colossians 3 15 that's a lot but it's not everything there's an awful lot more as
well just to let you know that you know when you come to the New Testament you'll find pieces spoken
about in all the letters you know so July the 11th 1923 we're talking about the new era because in
revealing the divine will Jesus is unleashing a new era of grace and glory okay
Louisa said I was praying and abandoning all of myself in the arms of my most sweet Jesus and with
the thought in my mind that was saying only for you this martyrdom of having to bother others
of being a burden to your ministers now the thing the thorn in her side is the priest coming
every day okay as I cannot do without letting the medal in my business look at the way she is dealing
with it I think it's brilliant these priests are supposed to be our spiritual directors they are
her connection with the bishop but the the lovely thing about Louisa is she tells us as she experiences
it and she says at the time they're meddling in my business I love that so the thing that's
lovely about her is she makes no attempt to be the pious person she makes no attempt at saying it
the way somebody expects me to say it she tells you how she experiences that's why I just love it
you know she's just so true to herself so she said they meddle in in my business in the things
that pass between me and Jesus the others are free they enter a state of stuff the others are
other victim souls Louisa is presuming other victim souls are different but usually victim
souls have to have a priest looking after them because they they need so much help I mean Patrick
Pio had to have a lot of help you know and in the end his whole community revolved around him you
know the others are free she says they enter into a state of suffering and they they can free
themselves by themselves yet how many times I prayed for him to free me but in vain now he has
explained to her over and over again why this is happening but she doesn't let it go and what she's
doing there is she's expressing us that if there's something really as we would say in Ireland killing
us we were not able to let it go we we complain and we moan and we complain and we moan and that's
what she's doing and I love that because again she's telling us she's real she's not pretending to be
something she isn't now while I was thinking of this and other things she said blessed Jesus came
all goodness and love and placing himself near me he said my daughter the greater the work I want
to do the more necessary it is that the soul I choose be unique and singular this is terribly
important and Louisa probably still doesn't grasp how great is the revelation that the Lord is
making through her and so what what has just been said there applies absolutely to blessed mother
with regard to redemption until Louisa with regard to the divine will so the work of redemption was
the greatest and I chose only one person endowing her with all gifts never conceded to anybody else
so that this person might contain so much grace as to be able to become my mother
and so that I might deposit in her all the goods of redemption and in order to keep my own gift
safe from the moment she was conceived until she conceived me I kept her hidden in the light
of the most holy trinity is not incredible so all her life was quite literally hidden because
she was with her parents after she was three then she was in the temple okay
so I kept her hidden in the light of the most holy trinity which was her custodian
and the blessed trinity had the office of directing her in everything that's Deuteronomy 32-12
Deuteronomy 32-12 the Lord alone was her guide then when I was conceived in her
virginal womb being the true priest and the head and the first of all priests I myself took on the
charge of keeping her and directing her in everything so that's the hidden life in Nazareth okay even
in the in the motion of her heartbeat and when I died I entrusted to her another priest which was
St. John a soul so privileged who contained all graces unique in the divine mind unique in history
I did not want to leave her without the assistance of a representative of mine up to her last breath
of course St. John was with her right up to her last breath have I perhaps done this to other
souls no because they did not contain so much good so many gifts and graces and therefore
so much custody and assistance wasn't actually necessary so now he comes to Louisa
and again he's going to explain why the priest has to come but this is at least his fourth time
chapter explained now my daughter you two are unique in my mind why she's the very first person
who has been born with the original sin to reach the divine will to reach the level of the divine
will now because he has lifted her to this level he opens the kingdom of the divine will and the
rest of us can come later because blessed mother had the divine will from the first instant of her
being and she had the immaculate conception then redemption could happen because of her
okay and the rest of us can trot along and take as much of redemption as we want that that's the
process that he's talking about there will not be either before or after you another person
for whom I will dispose as though forced by necessity the assistance of my ministers okay
having chosen you in order to deposit in you the sanctity the goods and the effects and the
attitude of my supreme will it will appropriate just and decorous it says here we would say right
for the very sanctity that my will contains that one of my ministers should assist you
and be the first depository of the goods which my divine will contains
now we've already met the fact that two of her spiritual directors have already died
and that as much of the divine will that they had taken in they benefited hugely in heaven and
of course Hannibal is is canonized as well um Hannibal de Francia so that the that these priests
should be the first depository of the goods which the divine will contain in other words the lord
wanted the official church to accept this mist first before anybody else so as to let them pass
from his lap into the whole body of the church so it's supposed to go through the priests to the
laity but at the moment is the other way around and what great attention is required of you and
of them of you in receiving from me like a second mother now in volume two he asked her to be a
second mother if you want the reference there um the great gift of my will and in knowing all
of its qualities of the priests in receiving them from you so that the fiat volantis tour
on earth as it is in heaven may be fulfilled in my church so the priests have to realize
they have to be involved if the our father is being fulfilled that is part of their mission
and so they were to be uh completely involved in it from the very beginning
I removed from uh wait a minute oh yeah you do not know how much I had to give you to dispose you
to this capacity in other words the enormity of the projities of grace that had to be given to her
to overcome her nature her uh training uh that you would get through the priests um to overcome all
the customs of the the church and all the rest of it so that I might deposit my will in you watch
this now what he says now is absolutely incredible I removed from you any seed of corruption that
means he removed concupisence he never did that before or since
he didn't have to do a requested mother because she had the exactly conception from the beginning
but from louisa she had to have the concupisence removed from her so that she could live at the
level of the divine will and be the the receptor of this incredible thing I purified your soul I
purified your very nature in such a way that neither do you feel anything for them nor the
day for you in other words the passions are not demanding anything from you and you're not looking
for anything from them you're only looking to me so concupisence is gone since the seed is missing
the seed is concupisence it is as if the fire were missing the firewood so none of the ordinary
temptations that we would go through she she was going through because concupisence had been removed
and even though I did not exempt you from original sin as I did with my dear mother by removing from
you the seed of corruption I worked another project of grace never conceded to anybody else now this
particular section is absolutely unique make sure you put VIP on it and envy and everything else that
you put on something because this aspect will always have to be said about louisa okay and he
says very clearly I never conceded this to anybody else because it was not right for my will thrice
holy to descend into and take possession of a soul which would be shaded even slightly by the
slightest corrupted breath now he said that about his mother that he could not have been born
conceived and born in her if there had been the slightest shade of sin and he's saying to louisa
that because the whole of the divine will has to go into her she has to be lifted that level as well
but the difference is that now one of us has been lifted to that level and because the gift has
been given to her then the door is left open for the rest of us to receive as much as we can
but since the lord hasn't removed concupuses from us I presume you understand we won't be sort of
at the height that she's at is that okay if i'm in the field at all i'll be glad i don't know about
you because this is incredible stuff isn't it um so by removing from you the seed of corruption I
worked another project of grace never conceded to anybody else because it was not right for my
will thrice holy to descend into and take possession of the soul that would be shaded even slightly
by the slightest corrupted breath my will would not have adapted itself to taking possession of her
to communicating its attitude to her had it seen any seed of corruption okay aziah 35 eight aziah
35 eight this is the seed of corruption revelation 21 27 he brews 1214 nothing unholy or unworthy can
enter the presence of god that's it finito okay and aziah 35 describes the highway to heaven of
the redeemed and it says very specifically in verse eight no unclean thing can be on this road
of course i could give you one john three two as well um where john says that um
someone who is truly in union with god does not sin there can't be sin in this person
and we know ourselves that to have any level of the divine will in us there can not be sin
it's as simple as that that's why don't be don't be um slow at telling somebody they're not ready
for divine will i just say to them look it's it's just live the level you're at and do what you can
to get ready because sin has got to be eliminated to go into the divine will and if it's said very
clearly to them uh they they won't have the problem that they would have by coming into class and
suddenly discovering that they can't continue so um jesus said just as i the word of the father
would not have adapted myself to being conceived in the womb of my celestial mother had i not
exempted her from original sin and then how many graces have i not given to you you think it's
nothing he says to her and therefore you think you give it no thought but when he says that to her
he's simply saying you've accepted this without even thinking about it and because it has happened
to you and you've accepted it you're not you're not realizing it's the enormous prodigy that it
actually is um and instead of thanking me he says you occupy yourself with thinking about what i've
disposed for you uh and about those i have placed around you well i want you to only follow my will
and she started obviously by saying that the priests were annoying her he says you have no idea
what i'm actually trying to do but you get your eyes off trivialities and try and put them on
the door it's typical us isn't it that the lord's trying to do something and then we distract ourselves
with with trivialities and so the next paragraph you're now being introduced to the higher volumes
which the messages are much longer okay you must know that this fulfillment of my will is so great
jesus said as to be numbered among the greatest works with the divinity has operated now please
put envy VIP or something on that which is what he's doing in the divine will is among the greatest
of the things that god has thing so god is trying to work with us little nothings to do this incredible
thing i think is marvelous and so the only thing i say to him is i want to throw my nothingness into
your own is that every second so that i don't i don't block you at any moment okay and i wanted
to be known he said there it is again you've got to teach others so that in knowing its greatness
and the immense good that it contains they they that his other souls will love it
esteem it and desire it three times the supreme divinity decided to operate add extra that means
on the outside of themselves number one the first was in creation and it was without the
intervention of any creature since none of them had yet come to the light of day the second time
that the blessed trinity operated add extra is in redemption and with it in a intervened a woman
the holiest and the most beautiful by celestial mother she was the channel and the instrument i
used in order to fulfill the work of redemption number three the third is the fulfillment of my
will to be done on earth as it is in heaven in other words the fulfillment of the our father
that is for the soul to live and operate with the sanctity and the power of our will now here you
have it in a nutshell what living in the divine will that the soul would be able to operate with
the sanctity and power of our will a work which is inseparable from creation and redemption
just as the sacroscient trinity is inseparable nor can we say that the work of creation has been
completed by us if our will as we decreed does not act in the soul and live with that freedom
sanctity and power with which it operates and lives in us now you see neither creation nor
redemption is complete until the human being comes back to god and lets them have complete
freedom with us then creation is complete and then redemption is complete as well so all three of
these fiats of god they're all together as one and he tells us as as we go along he loves doing
everything in threes because that represents the three of them okay even more this is the most
beautiful point the highest the brightest and the seal of the fulfillment of the work of creation
and redemption no this is it this is the icing on the cake these are divine decrees Jesus said
and they must have their full completion and in order to fulfill this decree we want to use
another woman and that's you the woman was the incitement the cause for which man the human race
fell into his misfortunes and we want to use the woman to put things in order and one of the things
that's fascinating in reading the way the lord works is the detail if a woman brought the disaster
she's decided that that means you say to the kids you brought the disaster into this room you put it
back and so you're teaching them order if you do that okay and i think if we don't teach children
order we get disorderly adults so the woman was the cause so the woman had to be used to put
things back in order and we want to use woman to put things in order to let man out of his
misfortunes and to give back to him decorum honor our true likeness just as he was created by us
so this is the what you get at the very beginning of each one of your volumes
that the call is to to return to the order and the place and the purpose for which we were created
that's what he's talking about here therefore be attentive and don't take things lightly he says
this is not just about anything this is about divine decrees now whatever about louisa thinking
that uh taking them lightly it's the problem is that one senior taking it lightly because the
man senior half the time doesn't really believe what's going on and these are about divine decrees
and about giving us the field to let us accomplish the work of creation and redemption
therefore just as we entrusted our mother to saint john that she might deposit in him and from him
to the church the treasures the graces and all my teachings which i had deposited in her during
the course of my life when she was entrusted to me and i acted as priests to her as i deposited
in her as in a sanctuary all the laws precepts and doctrines which the church was to possess
here you have one of these impossible sentences again okay let's go back
one of the reasons why john's gospel is much much much more rich than the others
is that john was with blessed mother all by himself for years after the resurrection
and she taught him everything and she taught him uh the deeper meanings of absolutely everything
you'll get this if you read maria val torta okay uh and it was john who was able to give
the others the deeper meanings of things because he was getting them from the source
um now who taught them about um the the incarnation and battle him and all the rest
she did it's the obvious okay um but if you read maria val torta you'll find that jesus told his
apostles as well but the all the deeper teachings that were to go on to the church uh was given
by blessed mother to john in those years she lived approximately 16 years after the resurrection
of jesus that was plenty of time to teach john personally okay um so jesus says here that he
deposited in his mother all the laws and precepts and doctrines of which the church was to possess
but the Protestants want to tell us that we made all this stuff up it's not interesting
whereas the church knew from the beginning but not everything was written and that's why we
we speak about tradition as well as as the scriptures and she faithful as she was and jealous of even
one word of mine look at that now one of the things that the bible says of the prophet samuel
was that he never allowed a word of god to fall to the ground look at this this is the same thing
jellus of even one word of mine deposited them in my faithful disciple john now when you go back to
the the prophet isiah he was living through a difficult time as well uh a hundred years before
the exile uh and he deposited all his teachings in his disciples hence when you read the book of
of uh uh isiah it goes through about 200 years of history um so he said blessed mother deposited them
in my faithful disciple john so that they might not be lost and therefore my mother has primacy
over the whole church so it was only the second Vatican council that cleared our mother of the
church wasn't that it uh so so i did with you jesus said since the spheat belong to us must serve
the whole church i entrusted you to a minister of mine that you may deposit in him everything i
manifested to you about my will the goods contained in it how the soul must enter into it how the
paternal goodness wants to open another era of grace placing his goods at which he possesses
in heaven in common with the creatures on earth and giving back to the soul our lost happiness
therefore be attentive that's a massive piece uh and i had to read it slightly quickly because the
the time is more than up uh we've only won't more tiny bit but i'll leave it till next week is that
okay sorry yeah you don't want to finish it tonight do you want to finish the last piece oh that's
all right that's okay this is i thought i was pushing you that's okay we'll finish it then so
july the 14th 1923 is the expectation of a new era the surest sign that it is near okay as i
was in my usual state my good jesus came but all afflicted it seemed to me that it could not attach
from me and with all goodness he told me my daughter i have come to make you suffer he said
don't you remember that when i wanted to chastise the human race uh and you didn't want me to do it
wanting to suffer yourself in their place and in order to make you content uh i told you that
instead of doing 10 for love of you i would do five now this is genesis 18 verses 16 to 32 you
remember the intercession of april ham for sardom and gomara now in the early volumes of louisa
louisa's intercession managed to get one third of a response from the lord now 33
diminishment of a chastisement for one human being praying is unbelievable what now he says he wants
to give her 50% is that absolutely incredible absolutely incredible now the nations want to fight
against one another he said and those who believe themselves to be the most powerful there were the
western nations are taking up arms to their teeth in order to destroy the weak nations this is about
total destruction i saw just an advertisement about the second world war on the television today
i was just flicking through something they said this was about total destruction it was not about
conquering that's exactly what jesus says here it's about total destruction uh this is why i've come
to make you suffer he said to give you that 50% that i promised you my justice will give to fire
and water the power of the office that they contain in order to destroy people and entire
cities now waters are of course the tsunamis and there have been terrible fires around the place
as well and therefore a little bit of your suffering is necessary in order to reduce the
chastisements by half now before i go on i have to say something that reads perfectly normal to you
doesn't it but you have forgotten that uh from volume seven up to volume ten louisa was complaining
all the time i've less sufferings i'm not really suffering why don't you let me suffer and he was
guiding her away from just being a victim soul to this new completely unique role of opening the
kingdom of the divine will you see and then uh by the time you get to volume 13 she has settled
down into this new thing and here she is in volume 15 and he brings her back to it but he had explained
back there in volume seven i think it is that um whether you suffer or don't suffer doesn't actually
matter because you're a victim soul anyway let me give you that as an example if you're married
whether you're sick or well you're still married whether you're at home at this moment or away from
home at this moment you're still married that's the state you have is that okay so he was saying to her
whether you suffer or not is not actually the issue the issue is that you're a victim soul and
everything you experience is part of that and she just hadn't had taken that into account okay so
it's slightly unusual then for him to say this to her at this particular point which is totally
ready because she was she was like the batteries ever ready you know now while he was saying this
he moved in my interior that's your luke what is it 17 21 some of them now you should get off my heart
as though holding many instruments in his hands and as he moved them sufferings and pains were
formed with such tearing of all my members that i don't know how i remained alive and when he would
see me moaning and shivering because of the intensity of the pains with the air of one who has triumphed
over everything he would say to me you are my life and with my life i can do whatever i want
now is he just glorying in her suffering no it's in seeing another christ willing to pay this price
to save his or her brothers and sisters and he will as we go on he will actually take her to heaven
and he will boast to the angels and saints in heaven nobody has loved him like this
it's absolutely amazing isn't it that's why he says you are my life and with my life i can do
whatever i want and he would continue his crafting to make me suffer may everything be for the glory
of god then afterwards he added my daughter the whole world is upside down gosh a century later
how would you even say it if it was a it was upside down a century ago and everyone is awaiting
changes peace and new things they themselves gather to discuss about it and they are surprised
at not being able to conclude anything and to come to any serious decisions so true peace does not
arise and everything resolves into words but not deeds and they hope and they have more
conferences they they hope that more conferences may serve to make serious decisions but they
wait in vain now isn't that a rerun of what you've heard on the news for the last number of years
all they're doing is gathering they have the g7 the g this and they they have the ministers of
this and they have the government of that and they all the governments coming together and they're
all talk and they're all there's nothing they come to no conclusions he said it's all in vain
in the meantime i should it should put beside that john 15 5 without me you can do nothing
in the meantime in this waiting they are in fear and some prepare themselves for new wars
some hope for new conquests so notice there's not clear motivation there some wouldn't mind
a war at all so they can make new conquests but with this the people are impoverished they are
stripped alive while they are waiting tired of the sad present era dark and broody which enwraps
them they wait and hope for a new era of peace and light and what jesus is saying is that the world
has actually shifted focus that everybody desperately wants a new era but the thing is
they want it on the wrong level okay the world is exactly at the same point as when i was about to
come on the earth and that tells you it's time for the second coming okay and when jesus actually
came the first time it was to a corrupt priesthood in israel now he would come to exactly the same
situation there's nothing new on the earth nothing at all he said all were waiting for a great event
a new era as indeed occurred it is the same now since the great event the new era in which the
will of god may be done on earth as it is in heaven is coming underlying that one everyone is awaiting
this new era tired of the present one but without knowing what the new thing is without knowing
what the change is about just as they didn't know it when i came upon the earth this expectation is
a sure sign that the hour is near but the surest sign is that i am already manifesting what i want
to do and that turning to a soul just as i turn to my mother in descending from heaven to the earth
i communicate to her my will and the goods and the effects that it contains so everything is ready
is that amazing it's just the end of volume 15